[Music]
I love jumping into problems when I find
that problem that I really care about
and I really want to see through I can't
really focus on anything else
commitment is definitely one way of
phrasing it
I've phrased it as well as just an
obsession and I'll continue to be
obsessed with it until the problem is
solved or I realize that I just for
whatever reason and incapable of solving
it I'm the son of two Hollywood
screenwriters they write sitcoms so
they're comedy writers and growing up in
a household border always laughing and
it was funny it was amazing they work
together and they always kind of work
for themselves and they were able to
kind of set the stage for their own
career and I really inherited that
heavily from them when I was a lot
younger I liked playing video games on
the computer but I wanted to be able to
modify the video games or maybe even
make my own video game and I realized
the tool required to do that was
programming so I was able to teach
myself how to program and seeing the
advancements around programming
especially with artificial intelligence
made me realize that there were
tremendous opportunities in a wide
variety of industries where you could
apply this programming tool science
there's really two themes in my life
that I think tie everything back
together one of those is human nature
and human psychology the other major
theme is this idea of kind of learning
the tools to create things really
revolve around technology and
programming and understanding new tech
as they emerge I was observing the crazy
advancements in artificial intelligence
deep learning computer vision and
realized that if we were to use these
extremely intelligent computer systems
to automatically identify things like
guns and knives we don't have to rely on
human beings staring the police images
to do
synapse technology provides automated
detection capabilities for x-ray
security checkpoints so we automatically
detect threats like guns knives and
ammunition as opposed to having to rely
on human operators we ran a study just
to give you a sense of how improved the
numbers are and we gave somebody who's
never seen one of these x-ray security
machines before and we compared that to
someone who's certified and trained on
these x-ray machines the person who's
never seen this x-ray machine before but
was aided by our software was able to
catch twice as many threats as the
person who is trained to catch threats
if we can keep one more person from
being shot in one of these horrific acts
of violence to me that is essentially
mission accomplished I graduated MIT in
three years and I knew that I wanted
some kind of fourth year I found
Stanford Business School and I thought
what could be better it felt immediately
relevant to what I was working on at the
company being surrounded by lectures and
professors and teachers and guests I
felt like I had that love and support
from some of the classes and the
experiences here it suddenly made me
realize just how valuable this place is
and how much I was able to get out of it
I learned more during my MBA two-year
then I ever could have at my company
alone over a decade of work my parents
from an early age always said you can do
anything you want in the world but be
your own boss and that's always really
resonated with me and I've always kind
of followed my passions and done exactly
that what gets me excited every day and
makes me want to wake up and go to work
is feeling like I'm solving genuine
problems in the world whether that's in
this case making the world a safer place
or whatever else it may be that's what
motivates me every day that's what gets
me excited and that's where I feel like
there's just tremendous opportunity in
the world
[Music]
you